car eux
[Musique]
bon
combien de vue fera cette vidéo combien
de vue fera cette vidéo au moins une
passe qu'il ya au moins toi qui regarde
la vidéo salue aujourd'hui on va faire
un prend voyance l'idée c'est de
recevoir des gens comme ça ou c'est dans
l'artistique bon peu importe les animaux
à la maison c'est ça oui oui incroyable
et donc comme vous l'avez but de leur
faire croire que je suis voyant mais
sans l'être en utilisant deux choses le
mentalisme principalement mais également
des recherches d'informations qu'ils ont
pu laisser traîner sur internet parce
que quand même on laisse traîner
beaucoup trop de choses sur internet
bref c'est pas mentaliste versus voyance
est vraiment mentalist qui se fait
passer pour un voyant et en même temps
je disais c'était un bon test si jamais
un jour la chaîne elle marche ou plus
toujours meuron convertir alors c'est un
voyant particulier c'est en voyant cas
des binettes et c'est un voyant cas pas
de fer à repasser
apparemment il faut le savoir c'est un
concept particulier cette vidéo c'est
une vidéo un peu grosse à mettre en
place une équipe partout
[Musique]
tais toi là qu'on est là un peu style et
j'avais peas et la chine ont fait le
plan sting alors tous mes bases y
partout autour de moi il y aura un
making-of d'ailleurs de cette vidéo dans
ma chaîne secondaire dans le lien est
dans la description dresser une vidéo
salut mon plus gros projet de l'année
avec le dos et comme avec le dos il me
fallait un partenaire pas n'importe
lequel puisqu'il va falloir qu'on fasse
des recherches rapides fiables et
efficaces en plein tournage pour
recevoir des informations qu'on a glané
sur les réseaux sociaux sur les
personnes qu'on m'apprend quai et c'est
pour ça que je suis allé voir voix de
plus pour dire fou finances auriez un
tournage de voyance ils ont dit oui je
vous présente ce petit bijou de
technologie le one + 7 t
reconnaissance faciale instantané je
sais pas si tu l'as vu s'ouvriront pas
on peut le revoir on peut le revoir
regarde c'est boum boum c'est incroyable
on a un écran hyper immersif parce qu'il
ya une toute petite encoche moi
franchement je l'avais pas vu qu'il
avait vu loïc mito on la voit un petit
peu quand même avec toute petite
ils ont réduit de 40% la lumière bleue
qui est généré par les écrans
ils ont amélioré la luminosité c'est à
dire quand en plein soleil
la luminosité a été augmenté de 27 % ce
qui fait qu'on voit mieux c'est le
principe et il sera quand même utile de
vous préciser pour terminer avec l'écran
qu'il consomme très peu d'énergie
associée à sa à la batterie de ouf duels
plus je peux voir faire l'article mais
ils ont encore amélioré
c'est un excellent produit de ce côté là
mais de l'autre côté nous découvrons
trois capteurs dont l' ultra grand-angle
de 117,2 grec avait été pas mal réclamé
à one plus avec le lancement de la gamme
7 voix de plus faut savoir aussi que ses
marques et hyper proche des utilisateurs
donc en fonction des retours qu'ils ont
ils vont faire des changements ou ne pas
les faire et discuté il ya une vraie
synergie entre la marque et les
personnes qui se servent des one plus
belle au heat il va poser cette caméra
et on fait la suite avec loane plus
toqué acuvue loïc ce taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 f c'est juste
exceptionnel
alors je vous dis comment va se passer
se prend on a contacté des abonnés qui
vont venir avec un ami ou quelqu'un de
leur famille qui ne me connaît pas et
qui est censé rencontrer en voyant un
voyant à pain en voyant ce pour un
tournage de télévision au quai d'où les
caméras qui vont être visible même des
crosby malkin tourne même pas et le
générique est devenu l'oit la réal mois
ces personnes là je vais essayer de leur
faire du co la ligne que je fais passer
pour de la voyance à l'aide d'un tarot
je vais inventer des histoires qui vont
servir de support pour crédibiliser et
ensuite l'utiliser un pendule pour faire
passer comme ça pour un médium presque
en même temps dans une autre pièce
pierre bock fait des recherches sur eux
sur internet et va m'envoyer une
information un peu bad as tu vois sur la
personne et grâce à la reconnaissance
faciale du voile plus qu'un sport tas
neigeux pourrait vite fait et discretos
prendre l'information et à la fin les
gens seront bluffés
parce que je serai meilleur voyant
l'idée c'est de
une séance alors une séance complète
durant environ deux heures entre 1h30 et
2h je sais pas si vous avez déjà
consulté des voyants et médiums choses
comme ça n'existait isme magnétiseur
donc vous m'avez dit vos prénoms sont
tapies signer à delhi a dit est ce que
vous voulez qu'on regarde quelque chose
sur votre vie sans être trop intime
alors bien machines hyper terre-à-terre
donc j'en ai fait assez chaud l'occasion
lui juste le travail le travail
ok je vous demandais de alors on va
commencer très classique avec le tarot
de marseille avec les arcanes majeurs je
vous demandais de les mélanger
vous les bras c'est ensuite vous les
posez vous couper de la main gauche et
pour refermer la coupe c'est vos plaques
si vous avez une question particulière
pensez-y tout en mélangeant et à l'amour
plutôt d'avoir quelqu'un pour le travail
et l'amour dont on peut faire les deux
on pourra faire les deux d'accord on
commence par quoi alors la mort le
travail ce travail le travail au noir
je vous laisse mélanger c'est l'écart by
tarot de marseille je vous laisse les
mélanger à la province ont ce qu'ils
méritent ce serait le travail du travail
ok je fermais la coupe s'il vous plaît
et vous allez étaler les cartes de la
main que vous voulez et me confier cinq
cartes donc ce qu on appelle ça le
tirage rapide donc on connaît la
thématique de base de travail
vous êtes posé une question et ça c'est
censé nous donner la réponse ici j'ai le
contexte actuel qui vous êtes ici je
vais avoir le chemin suivant la
regardera à la fin ça c'est tout ce qui
est positif pour que s'accomplisse dans
la direction que vous voulez tout ce qui
est négatif
et ça c'est le conseil on va voir par
rapport à votre situation actuelle
ok on est sur le mat alors le match on
l'appelle aussi le fou c'est la carte
qui n'a pas de numéro c'est la seule
carte des tarots qui a aucun numéro
pourquoi parce que elle est dans
l'instabilité mais dans le bon sens du
terme
dire que c'est à dire que c'est un
moment charnière ça veut dire que par
exemple je sais pas ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui mais il ya de très fortes
chances que ça change est plutôt dans
les prochains mois voire une année un
objectif à l'horizon qui existent mais
qui a besoin que de moi pour exister
je sais pas dans contre vous travaillez
mais en tout cas c'est
une chose est sûre c'est que il ya une
forme d'indépendance ou dans une domaine
d'activité qu en train de se monter à
bord ont quelque chose de très
intéressant qui les rebute lhermitte
il est éclairé c'est à dire qu'il est
dans une situation et qui regarde s'il
ya un autre chemin potentiel donc je
sais pas si c'est le cas pour vous donne
travail aujourd'hui mais on regarde dans
une autre direction
en plus on l'a dans le bon sens on ne
l'a pas l'envers apparemment c'est à
vous parler de bête en mieux la mort
c'est la meilleure carte en live c'est
un autre tirage aujourd'hui et on l'a
souvent dans les éléments très positifs
rappelez vous ai dit quoi qu'il arrive
ce qui est positif c'est la grande
rupture c'est le changement c'est le
renouveau c'est la nouvelle vie c'est en
balance tout et on repart sur quelque
chose ici ça veut dire que c'est génial
en fait est que cette rupture faudra pas
en avoir peur et que ça peut faire peur
parce que la mort fait peur et donc le
combat vers l'inconnu la nouvelle de
volontaires le confort mais en fait
c'est une excellente chose
le diable c'est le symbole ultime de la
liberté c'est à dire que dans la
mythologie le diable ou lucifer serait
celui qui sait pas je ne lui et qui a
été banni en fait la symbolique de
l'enfer c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a
re créer son propre univers avec ses
propres règles et si on enlève tout le
côté bien et mal là dedans le chariot ça
veut dire qu'on est sur quelque chose en
mouvement ces attaques ont a quelque
chose dans un domaine de la
représentation je sais pas si vous
travaillez au niveau du luxe de la
beauté du faste de ou peut-être des
grands hommes d'affaires des grands
hommes politiques mais il ya des
personnes qui sont beaucoup regardé
c'est pour ça que sur le chariot on est
toujours en hauteur et on est sur du
mouvement donc ça peut être si le
mouvement sur des personnes qui voyagent
beaucoup soin de l'information qui
voyage elle aussi beaucoup ce que vous
allez faire plus tard c'est quelque
chose qui vous mettra en avant en
lumière alors ça peut être un métier de
représentation ça peut être vous qui
fait des discours ça peut être ce genre
de choses mais du coup le conseil c'est
que l'élément qui pourrait être bloquant
c'est de vouloir être trop dans la
lumière trop vite trop fort l'appareil
un des conseils d'interprétation par
rapport à ces trois cartes c'est de
séparer le travail de la vie personnelle
ce sera très important
oui c'est vrai les bébés ce sera ce sera
vraiment essentiel le bateleur on est
alors encore plus précisément dans le
travail des mains apparemment oui
le bateleur y créer créer du bonheur
mais il crée son propre bonheur c'est un
double bonheur le bateleur au niveau du
négatif qu'est ce qu'on a on à l'étoile
on à l'étoile c'est assez rigolo parce
que par rapport au fait qu'on ait des
personnes en représentation ça veut dire
que le contre ça va être des questions
d'ego de ces mêmes personnes pas les
mêmes exactement mais dans l'entourage
donc dans votre travail
ces mêmes personnes il doit y en avoir
qui ont pour parler très bêtement c'est
de choisir mes mots comme rien n'est
compliqué grosso modo est long il ya des
personnes qui ont un melon énorme qui
prennent énormément de classe et qui
savent un peu mieux vous un peu tous ces
personnes là ce ne sera pas la peine de
les écouter ce sera pas elle les bonnes
personnes ce sera les contres la
conclusion c'est la tempérance alors la
carte de la tempérance au delà du mot
propre de ce moment c'est aussi les
changes
ça se fait à plusieurs à la laddh de
vase c'est à dire que la réussite elle
passe par un combiné d'associations
d'idées d'associations de compétence
sera pas quelque chose que vous ferez
seul en tout cas ce que vous serez au
moins deux voire plusieurs sûr sûr sûr
vos objectifs et vous agirez avec
tempérance c'est à dire avec la
réflexion du pape est ce que ça vous
parle un petit peu où l'argent c'est oui
oui ce sage suisse convient nous deux en
ce moment d'accord ok vous avez roger
voilà quelque chose comme ça ok bombe
est super ah oui c'est super mais pour
l'instant je pense qu'on va être sur
quelque chose d'à peu équilibrée en de
prendre les bonnes décisions ou quelque
chose comme ça on est sûr la justice il
n'ya pas plus équilibre avec la justice
c'est-à-dire de toujours peser le pour
et le contre
tout en gardant en tête que une rupture
sera nécessaire pour atteindre ce chemin
là voilà je sais pas si ça vous parle
tout ça c'est vrai donc donc tant mieux
et vous dis c'est si c'est ce dont vous
avez envie c'est plutôt positif à la
carte sont assez positives là dessus
mais ça vous arrive ça va vous apporter
la force de suivre ce chemin là donc
c'est quelque chose d'aussi clair que ça
c'est à dire que au delà de
l'épanouissement ça va vous rendre plus
forte dans les domaines donc si vous
êtes dans le jeu rien à dire j'ai très
peu de choses à dire par rapport aux
autres zones de consultation qu'on a
fait parce que c'est là la grille de
lecture est très claire à ce que ça vous
parle déjà tout ça oui oui oui ça c'est
super voilà je ne sais pas si ça répond
un petit peu on va aller un tout petit
peu plus loin alors ça c'est jeudi que
j'ai pas de dons et je prends un pendule
donc ça étonne toujours mais pour moi le
pendule est aussi hasardeuse que les
cartes
ça permet simplement d'avoir des
informations on voit où est ce que le
pendule réagi et là c'est pas vous qui
allez vous poser des questions c'est moi
qui vais m'opposer intérieurement et
après je vois si j'ai des intuitions qui
me viennent ou pas grosso modo je me
pose des questions je ne fais pas cas de
tous qu'elle marquait c'est juste pour
moi un petit peu comme quand on jouait à
chaud froid qu'on est des petits je me
posais une question et puis plus aient
réagi l'appui ça veut dire que j'ai bon
vous voyez j'ai beaucoup moins oui ou un
petit peu à l'échelle de la france
ah oui d'accord mais moi j'ai en fait je
cherchais le mouvement pour vous et j'ai
beaucoup de mouvements sur vous passé
proche donc c'est vrai oui d'accord ok
arrêté d'y penser j'ai quelque chose qui
est très liée à vous depuis tout à
l'heure c'est pour ça que je le relance
à chaque fois mais ce palier forcément à
votre travail à votre c'est pas prendre
de sens littéral mais c'est c'est la
rapidité la précision
rapide précis ordonné rapide aussi
beaucoup rapide très rapide ça allait
vite précise structuré avec le sens du
détail chose qui vous parle qui résonne
pour nous on s'est lâché dans la vie je
suis femme assez structuré il faudra
quand même les bajon pouvoir avancer au
yen on essaie on y sort le changement
radical j'ai quelque chose de très très
très très très gris et terne on va dire
en termes de vibrations aujourd'hui mais
même visuellement dedans lorsque vous
vous devez voir on partirait vers
quelque chose de très colorées ses
jolies la couleur il ya les choix joie
beaucoup de femmes autour de vous
beaucoup d'amour dans les deux sens
pendant d'autres cadres
d'accord j'ai un voyage pour vous c'est
pas moi qui vais vous l'offrir c'est
vous qui allez c'est pas tout de suite
mais ça se prépare vraiment c'est pas du
travail n'est ce pas des vacances c'est
autre chose et ça plutôt dans le nord de
l'europe
ok je vais en russie c'est vrai je
prépare mon voyage pour être ici vous
allez en russie la bientôt oui bien sûr
c'est vraiment d'accord auquel à pied ok
donc du coup je vous apprends rien alors
parce que je ne sais pas ça dépend de
mon passeport c'est un décor ok ben moi
j'ai un voyage un voyage nord de
l'europe
pas forcément tout de suite par contre
moi j'aurais plus dit
six 6 mois à nancy - hockey et vous y
allez pourquoi si c'est parce que je
suis né là bas je suis russe en d'accord
on verrait donc alors pour moi vous
retournerez à l'étranger mais que par
des cordes période pour travailler pour
le personnel s'est vidée en voyage mais
vous vous irez aussi pour le travail
mais pour des courtes périodes est pas
là où vous êtes allez vous vous étiez en
europe
il est resté en europe ils font entre
alliés espagne ou italie un des deux est
hélas à plus d espèce de semaine de
travail
le ter états unis ou alors plutôt
vraiment dans dans le nord côté suède
norvège vous fait des sports extrêmes du
snowboard et choses comme ça d'être un
mach et ouais je fais du sport action
je pars surtout sur la moto à moto car
les vitesses d'accord ok c'est rigolo
parce que pour le coup la moto on est
vraiment sur quelque chose de forcé de
la vitesse c'est pas de la vitesse folle
c'est l'histoire de précision la synchro
rôle précis et clair rangée qu'elle je
veux revenir un peu sur le travail
poissy d'aller voir un peu plus loin il
ya un côté artiste et vendeurs mais plus
plus artiste que vendeur pas vous hein
le domaine dans lequel vous allez
travailler c'est un peu lié à l'artiste
ou alors c'est pour les artistes ou c
dans l'artistique mon peu importe le
vendeur gelé tout le temps c'est à dire
carrément randonnée aussi si vous êtes
en train de créer quelque chose il faut
bien vendre quelque chose à perdre ou
pas aller voir les amers les amours
contre dans l'artistique aussi dit aussi
parce que pour l'instant on est dans
l'artistique
[Musique]
je vois de ce qu'on appelle l'amour à
tous les niveaux à la mort de ce qu on
fait l'amour de ses enfants l'amour de
l'amitié l'amour des animaux jus ou
moins autant des mots dit rien on va se
faire un truc un peu rigolo deux animaux
la maison c'est ça oui oui incroyable
après il ya une certaine logique en fait
un yaya n'y a pas tellement de hasard le
chiffre dont on le retrouve partout et
puis on a le bateleur alors on se dit
bon deux animaux cela c'est plus de la
voyance et de la logique
un chien et un chat on a les deux voilà
c'est ça dans le course et le monde très
bien le monde c'est la famille le monde
c'est le foyer par vraiment définition
qui est quelque chose vers lequel il
faut tendre en tout cas si vous voulez
quelque chose d'épanouissement pas un
conseil personnel cg interprète les
cartes bleues c'est la diversité me
montre donc si sam et en a même pas que
vous ayez et chiens et chats chez vous
n'êtes même pas son rôle c'est vraiment
la complexité à la remettant le contre
le compte de ce qui va nous intéresser
et le contre
peut être violent à la tension
la force d'accord ok bon vieux badal
c'est pas c'est à fin mars y insérera
pour vous ouais ok c'est super et en
effet gérard chaliand un chien un chat
un chat
j'ai juste boire un terminé la
conversation parce que je vous avoue que
ça me prend un petit peu grâce à vous
avez un chat et un chien
je vais voir ce que je peux trouver jour
sur facebook est ce que je peux voir
juste un verre d'eau si c'est possible
ou pas oui apparentés parce que
j'aimerais vous creusez votre travail
je vais tout simplement les coûts que
pour voir ce que quelqu'un qui compte
beaucoup pour dans votre vie mais je
pense que vous avez peut-être tout
simplement un chien on va tous mes
parents un chien d'après paul et ma
copine quand beaucoup pour moi ubs pense
pas que j'aurai passé de confusion que
je vais chercher son oncle par tout ce
que tu peux trouver ça c'est marrant
j'avais un truc avec la luminosité n'est
plus passé là vous devez se regarder
c'est un peu plus est-ce que je peux
boire un verre de fait extrêmement chaud
je ne sais pas ce que vous voulez que
j'essaie de trouver le nom de votre
chien abba branchements il vous y
arrivez alors là on sait son chien il
s'appelle qui s'appelle les diodes trop
bien je veux non non non je ne remets
pas d'y arriver mais c'est quelque chose
que je peux m'amuser à faire
je veux juste voir si on peut me donner
un indice sur la première lettre pour
moi j'ai l'intuition que votre chien est
dans la carte
je suis sur les toiles j'avais vraiment
envie de tenter un prénom mais non
malaisien parce que vous avez vous
arrive de ce prénom que je peux refaire
avec ses lettres avec les lettres des
toiles c'est elliott elliott
c'est vous qui m'avez donné est pas
possible
j'ai même pris votre main pour me donner
les toiles ça c'est assez impressionnant
c'est un chien je viens mais prêts non
plus j'ai envie et ça fait bien
et ses chiens vous avez grandi avec ou
pas non j'ai vendu une partie avec j'ai
eu un chien avant est d'accord est venue
se rajouter j'ai comme des prénoms qui
vont pas du tout
10 mx j'ai une intuition alors je peux
je peux l'essayer mais c'est pas faux
des fois c'est un peu à côté j'ai parlé
de moto alors des fois ça me parasites
j'espère et j'ai des noms de voitures
qui me viennent j'ai fait ferrari
mustang roll sujet des trucs comme ça
un rapport à mon chien s'appelle mustang
d'accord ok bon ben alors on marche pas
j'ai marché constitue en dessous des
vacances je me trouve une petite route
où j'ai reconnu la corse alors là c'est
un peu plus passé alors je m'aventure
quand même mais j'ai un voyage très
récent pas très loin pas papa en france
france mais pas beaucoup plus loin dooya
et celia l'amour profond et ça c'est
vraiment une valeur qui qui désavouent
parle bien oui non oui c'est les
vacances encore chez ma fille obèse se
parle c'est très bien vous avez deux
filles dans trois filles trois filles
d'accord guesdon tessa toutes ces femmes
désamour il est programmé sur plusieurs
plateaux d'artistes aux quelques la
mouche en plus ça va bien
le passé fait un métier directif
aujourd'hui quelque chose où vous prenez
la décision mais c'est 1000 décisions à
la seconde et ça bouge beaucoup
oui d'accord d'accord ça va vous
demander d'être très créative alors plus
vous êtes créatif puis à jouer autour de
vous je sais pas si c'est le bon terme
et j'ai comme un public pour vous et
j'ai comme un public aussi pour vous
mais maintenant et vous ayez un peu de
maintenant et beaucoup de plus tard donc
voilà je sais pas si ça marche pour vous
et vous votre public vous l'aurez toute
votre vie mais alors s'il ya un truc de
que je peux vous demander ce que vous
faites sans indiscrétion de professeurs
professeur m
j'ai un public captif il n'a pas le
choix ils n'ont pas le choix mais il
paye pas son essai dans l'artistique
voulons y être c'est dans le théâtre ce
genre de choses
ok ok eh bien écoutez il faut commencer
à se lancer c'est la meilleure ville
pour sa série en faire plein de scènes
ouvertes ici après il ya juste un secret
que je vous dis pas par rapport à ça à
ma manière de faire c'est vrai il ya
quelque chose que je vous cache
je vous cache que depuis le début de la
séance depuis que vous êtes à 6 vous
êtes complètement piéger par votre ami
et que je ne suis pas voyant je suis
désolé
mais si les voyants du tout mais j'ai
d'autres jettent et révélation parce que
j'ai pas fait n'importe quoi n'importe
comment
ici et maintenant vous venez juste là
l'instant juste pas si vous l'avez
ressenti de vous faire piéger par
guillaume parce que je suis pas du tout
voyant je suis désolé pierre est ce que
vous connaissez le mentalisme oui je
suis pas voyant je suis mentaliste
alors d'un côté je vous ai piégé parce
que j'ai aucun don et j'ai dit n'importe
quoi
de l'autre côté j'ai analysé qui vous
étiez psychologiquement elle le savait
c'était un petit pierre et je suis
mentaliste par contre c'est à dire que
je peux faire ce que font des voyants
mais je n'ai aucun dont je n'ai pas de
fla je n'ai rien du tout et je pense que
les voyant non pas 2 dont la plupart du
temps où pour moi dans ce important de
temps n'ayons pas peur des mots puisque
je sais faire ce qu'ils font sans rien
mais donc tout ce que je vous ai dit je
le dis par rapport à ce que je vois de
vous par contre en profil psychologique
en ce que vous êtes etc et je suis moi
même sur scène depuis plus de 15 ans est
ce que je vous ai dit c'est vraiment les
conseils que je vous donnerai sans carte
c'est un pendule sauriens je me suis dit
comment je peux continuer à parler de
2,2 du futur potentiel qu'elles auraient
sur scène donc j'ai ce que je vous ai
dit c'était des vrais conseils
j'ai profité d'avoir ça comme support
pour dire ce que je pensais vraiment et
je pense vraiment que vous êtes sur un
mouvement que vous avez un pouvoir de
décision
hyper lucide et hyper fort que vous avez
une stabilité émotionnelle comme j'ai
rarement vu donc tout tout tout ce que
je disais dans le côté positif
gardez-les vraiment et si c'est créatif
alors que vous ne faites pas du créatif
aujourd'hui je réitère mon conseil devra
du jugement
mais c'est ça te fait quoi
petit bond dans le temps on a terminé
cette vidéo et j'ai même eu le temps de
regarder un petit peu d'erreurs et je me
dis c'est vraiment incroyable ce qui
s'est passé des fois j'aurai avec elliot
ou étoiles ça c'est juste du acer mais
c'était trop bien pour crédibiliser le
truc j'espère que ce concept là il vous
a plu dites moi dans les commentaires
mais tu es un pou si ça ça vous a plu et
surtout un gros merci aux one plus bas
encore suivi sur un projet un peu
délirant comme avait pu l'être le credo
jouvet un lien dans la description pour
aller voir le donc le nouveau one plus
c'est ptet century allez voir ça et moi
j'ai un peu qui fait me faire passer
pour un voyant je ne mentirai pas une
reconversion possible allez abonnez-vous
à très bientôt ciao